Speaker 1: A White House press secretary,
Jen Psaki, has tested positive for COVID and
of course, the question was.
Well, when was she with Joe Biden and what's
going on, and it actually turns out that she
hasn't been around Joe Biden for a little
bit and is not on Joe Biden's current trip
to Europe, apparently because many in her
family had tested positive.
So here's the report from CNN.
Psaki tests positive for COVID last saw Biden
Tuesday.
White House Press Secretary Jen Psaki, who
dropped off President Joe Biden's international
trip shortly before he departed, has tested
positive for coronavirus after members of
her household did.
Psaki said she last saw Biden Tuesday outside
while masked before the president departed
for Rome for the Group of 20 summit, and that
she tested negative several times in between.
Psaki said she was disclosing the positive
test result quote out of an abundance of transparency,
adding she experienced mild symptoms and is
working remotely.
It's unlikely Psaki could have infected Biden
with COVID 19.
Several physicians told CNN Sunday.
Based on the timeline of MBS Psaki's testing
negative for multiple days following her last
encounter with Biden, which was also outside
and masked, therefore very low risk in and
of itself.
Dr. Leana Wen, a CNN medical analyst and former
Baltimore city health commissioner, said in
an email.
The White House announced Thursday Psaki would
no longer join Biden on his trip abroad for
the at least the first few days, citing a
family emergency.
White House Deputy Press Secretary Karine
Jean-Pierre instead traveled with the president.
Jen Psaki put out a statement about this,
where she said on Wednesday, in coordination
with senior leadership at the White House
and the medical team, I made the decision
not to travel with the four on the foreign
trip with the president due to a family emergency,
which was members of my household testing
positive for COVID 19.
Since then, I have quarantined and tested
negative via PCR for COVID on Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
However, today I tested positive for COVID.
While I have not had close contact in person
with the president or senior members of the
White House staff since Wednesday and tested
negative for four days after that last contact.
I am disclosing today's positive test out
of an abundance of transparency.
I last saw the president on Tuesday when we
sat outside more than six feet apart and wore
masks.
Thanks to the vaccine, I have only experienced
mild symptoms, which has enabled me to continue
working from home.
I plan to return to work in person at the
conclusion of the 10 day quarantine following
a negative rapid test, which is an additional
White House requirement beyond CDC guidance.
Taken out of an abundance of caution, so she's
vaccinated.
So is Joe Biden outside masks to vaccinated
people?
Transmission risk is almost zero.
I say I don't say zero because strange things
happen when you have bell curve distribution
of things and unexplainable things happen
incredibly unlikely that Joe Biden would get
COVID.
In this case, she correctly assesses her risk
is lower and her risk of a serious case is
lower because she's vaccinated.
That's true.
Now there are people, opportunists and just
ignorant people who will see this.
And once again, much like with the death of
Colin Powell, say this is proof that the vaccines
don't work.
And of course, any one anecdote doesn't tell
us much about at a population level what does
and doesn't work about vaccines.
The fact that Colin Powell died despite being
vaccinated, given that he was 84 and immunocompromised
in more than one way, doesn't really tell
us anything about the effect that a population
level of vaccination and much the same way
when Jen Psaki says thanks to the vaccine,
I have mild symptoms.
That's not really an empirical statement.
Statistically speaking, she's likely to have
fewer symptoms thanks to being vaccinated
any individual, though.
It's harder to make such a statement, but
her general assessment is correct by being
vaccinated.
She's at lower risk for a serious case, and
unfortunately there are many people who either
don't understand the science or don't want
to understand it because they have preconceived
notions or desires about what they believe
the vaccine to do, where they will say, What's
the point of getting vaccinated?
Psaki was vaccinated and she got it well.
She's she's working at home and she seems
to feel mostly OK.
So that's the latest.
Very unlikely that Joe Biden could have received
the virus or been what's the word that she
would have spread the virus to Joe Biden in
the situation that was described, particularly
when she continued testing negative
for
several days?